you are truly flawless what is the
secret to looking so amazing
I don't always feel I look so amazing
even Salma Hayek has her off-days
insecurities like everyone like what
like I'm gonna tell you hard to believe
but Salma Hayek turns 50 in September
and let's be honest she's never looked
better do you feel sexier than ever at
49 no I still feel a little bit because
my husband is very good making me feel
like I still got it but you know what
it's okay it's not the most important
thing in my life two three the sex
I spoke with Salma on Tuesday at the
premiere of her new movie September's of
Shiraz in theaters June 24th she showed
me her secret trick to staying fit no
gym necessary I don't like to exercise
but I have this woman in London that
taught me how to do everything she
showed me a way to rearrange the muscles
and the way you operate with them and
use them in your everyday life it's
wonderful to be present with your body
instead of just collapsing into the
bones are you doing it right now are you
straightening tightening it's not
tightening tighten your abs is that not
it it's not tension it's relaxing it's
tightening other things no doubt Salma
is physical perfection for
eight-year-old daughter Valentina is her
mini-me do you think that more kids are
in your future hey you're superwoman you
can do anything girl
I already did superwoman with 42 I
already
I also am very blessed because I have
three stepchildren so I have a family of
four kids so point you know